I had a C section,
and it was wonderful.
I've always heard really bad things about them.
I've always heard horror stories,
but I wanted to make a little video
just telling my story and how absolutely amazing it was.
I walked into the operating room,
my doctor and all the nurses were so nice, so calming.
Lay down on the table,
had the spinal put in by my doctor,
and then it was almost time to meet my baby.
Being in the operating room was the closest to heaven
I have ever felt in my entire life.
They did a cool thing
where they put a clear tarp in front of me
so I was able to see my baby come out.
And my doctor right away
pushed him up to the plastic chart
so I could look at him.
He was crying.
He was beautiful.
He was perfect.
Immediately went and weighed him,
and my husband got to cut the cord.
I was completely awake,
completely coherent for the entire thing.
And as soon as they were finished stitching me up,
I got to hold my baby,
do skin to skin,
and breastfeed.
I was up and walking around
the whole floor of the hospital that night,
and my scar healed up nicely.
You can barely see it,
and I can even wear a string bikini now.
If I could relive that day,
I would do it again and again,
and I wouldn't change a thing.